don't believe me just watch
[Music]
we are one step closer to historic lunar
launch one step that's close artemis one
rolled out at florida kennedy space
center yesterday this is the first time
in 50 years that a rocket capable of
sending humans to the moon is on the
launch pad mark straussman is near a
launch pad 39b as you see on a very
foggy morning there mark nothing like
the fog rolling in at 7 24 right before
you go on the air so we'll have to
believe you that it's back there
good morning gail yeah you and i are
friends so you're going to have to just
trust me in this one that behind me in
the fog is really something special a
huge rocket the the biggest rocket most
powerful not the biggest but the most
powerful rocket that nasa has ever built
and a milestone moment it's
322 feet tall and will generate 8.8
million pounds of thrust after liftoff
getting this rocket to the pad was
something to see a crawler last night
carried it all the way here top speed
get this 0.8
miles per hour the four mile trip took
eight hours the mission artemis one will
be a crewless test flight the rocket
will send the orion capsule on a
multi-week mission around the moon and
back but first in a couple of weeks nasa
will have a full-scale practice
countdown fully fueling the rocket the
countdown will stop 10 seconds before
liftoff nasa plans to launch artemis one
in a couple of months if this mission
goes well nasa will put astronauts on
the next rocket in 2024
followed by a lunar landing no earlier
than 2025 but first things first this
practice countdown really has to go well
for uh with artemis if nasa's moon
dreams are going to stay on schedule
tony it's exciting it's very exciting
how do you move a big rocket slowly
thank you